now more on that global reaction Russia
announced this morning that it's closing
the border with China because of fears
over the coronavirus which has been
blamed for at least a hundred and
seventy deaths just across that border
in China
ramie inocencia is in Beijing for us
tracking the Chinese response to the
crisis
ramie we keep hearing about restrictions
and bans where do things stand where you
are sure thing and good morning Tony
basically ninety nine percent of all
cases that have happened in the world
have happened right here in China there
is no cure or no vaccine just yet and of
course as you as you might expect as
these infections continue to rise panic
is also rising take a look at this video
that we've got for you because even just
outside of the capital here in Beijing
villages have started to physically
block themselves off from the capital
using mounds of soil to barricade roads
people are even standing guard to keep
Outsiders from coming in and this really
is reminiscent of the tactics used
during the the massive SARS outbreak in
2003 when I lived here then and actually
more people in China have now been
infected by the corona virus then by
SARS globally the good thing is that
that hasn't happened just yet we're just
a few hundred people away from passing
that mark now there is a bit of good
news more than 100 people in some of the
hardest hit provinces have now recovered
from the virus and they are out of the
hospital but the business impact is just
starting more and more global businesses
for example are freezing their China
operations for example Starbucks has
closed more than half of its stores IKEA
has closed all of its stores and the
companies are restricting travel for the
likes of Amazon Facebook as well as
Apple and Google has suspended all of
its operations here in the country not
to mention Hong Kong and Taiwan as well
Gael seeing in everybody in those hazmat
suits is very disconcerting thank you
very much ray me you know sintió
reporting from Beijing